we are here to present the award for
international feature film which is
particularly exciting for me since i
come from an international country that
for many americans may seem exotic and
different
canada
probably
oh
okay i didn't even know that france was
in canada that's crazy
that is crazy you know i it's a
i got a thing for canadians
oh you do
yeah i like that circle bacon
okay uh um the men with the jackets that
ride on mooses with the hats yeah i
could do that uh huh that motions beard
the accents
accent yeah that letter actually it's
the vowels yeah we're gonna we're gonna
need to unpack that one yeah i like that
here's the nominees for best
international feature film
from japan drive my car directed by
ryusuke hamakuchi
[Music]
from denmark flee directed by jonas
boyer rasmussen
from italy the hand of god directed by
paulo sorrentino
[Music]
from bhutan lunana a yak in the
classroom directed by pauwo chunyung
dorji
from norway the worst person in the
world directed by your king trier
[Music]
and the oscar goes to
drive my car
[Applause]
[Music]
this is the fifth oscar and 14th
nomination for japan
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you very much
oh
you are the oscar
hold on
yeah
i'd like to thank all the members of the
academy for having us here
and
i'd like to thank
janice films scishow
wanna media150 and cinetic for bringing
drive my car to united states thank you
very much
[Music]
and
i also would like to
[Music]
just moment
i
i also would like to thank
the actors here this is
and i'd like to thank all the actors who
could not come here especially tokumira
who dropped the less of 900 beautifully
in the film
mirror song pretty much
[Music]
thank you very much
you